socotra is a unique island an island
that remained isolated from the world
until 2002 when a small airport was
built for the first time with its
landscape socotra has stimulated over
the centuries the imagination of many
travelers with its peculiar umbrella
shaped trees the socotra dragon trees
according to one of the old local
stories the first seed of dragon trees
sprouted in the exact spot where two
brothers darsha and sama chose to fight
to death that's a story that kinda
reminds us of cain and abel in the bible
in arabic this peculiar kind of tree is
known as the blood of the true brothers
for centuries the islanders have used
the reddish sap of this tree as an
ointment with magical properties and
it's no coincidence that the dragon tree
has become over time the most
recognizable symbol of this island a
place ends out with a biodiversity more
alien than terrestrial socotra is an
island blast with more than 700 endemic
species on flora and fauna unique in
their kind and thanks to which in 2008
unesco appointed the island a world
heritage site to be preserved and
protected nature is the true master of
socotra a beauty that has always
inspired me to get interested in the
events of this island so much so that i
hope one day to be able to visit it
although i don't see that as a feasible
thing at the moment bizarre plants
untouched and tremendously fascinating
shores and unspoiled highlands for many
socotra is a piece of paradise but for
others it's just a barren land to be
exploited located in the indian ocean in
a position which makes it geographically
part of the african continent sokotra is
closer to somalia than to yemen from the
somali coast the island is about 240
kilometers away while from the yemeni
coast it's more than double this
distance has contributed in large part
to the isolation and sense of mystery
that arab persian and african sailors
felt about such a remote island the
archipelago of socotra is formed by
three other small strips of land abdal
kuri darsa and sama the six thousand
inhabitants living on the island have
always relied on fishing and on the
cultivation of date poems and despite
belonging politically to yemen since
1999 the islanders half shiite and half
sonny boast their own culture and a
different language sokotri a semitic
language even older than arabic and
whose origin is still an arcane mystery
up to this day socotra find itself
embroiled in a civil war that has been
ravaging yemen since 2015. sokotra
became the epicenter of a power struggle
between the houthi rebels and the
central government but it became also
the place of another secondary conflict
the one between the united arab emirates
and the yemeni government of mansur hadi
the situation in yemen has been tragic
for over six years to be exact since
hadi was forced by shiite rebels
belonging to the ansar allah group
better known as houthi to resign from
its presidency abandon the capital sena
and leave it under the control of the
rebels the war in yemen is better known
as a proxy war a conflict where the real
actors are quite different from those
facing each other on the battlefield
under the surface yemen is actually
disputed on one side by the saudis
supported by the rest of the gulf
countries and the us which approved the
official government of adi and on the
other side there's iran which in
historical contrast to the saudi
monarchy supports the rebellion of the
houthis seeing it is as a possibility to
expand the sphere of influence directly
in the arabian peninsula we'll talk more
about the war in yemen in another video
this is not the case i'll just focus now
on socotra known as the jewel of the
gulf of aden sokotra is situated off the
horn of africa overlooking the baba
mondeb strait which connects the red sea
to both the gulf of aden and the arabian
sea the tensions surrounding socotra are
many every day more than 3 million oil
barrels travel from the persian gulf to
the indian ocean ships on this route
travel west across the arabian sea into
the gulf of aden then turn north
entering the red sea through the narrow
babel mandel passage before going up to
the suez canal the socotra archipelago
occupies a critical position on the
route to babel mondeb zakotra's central
location also makes it an ideal
launching point for interdicting pirates
and smugglers it protects the trade
routes and all the fishing communities
along the horn of africa and the
southern coast of yemen from iran to
somalia and from eritrea to qatar in
india for years international regional
powers have struggled to establish bases
around the horn of africa to have a
strategic advantage over all these
nations are the united arab emirates
which since 2018 have maintained a
military presence on the island to
support the cts which is the southern
transitional council an entity whose
purpose is to achieve the separation of
south yemen from the rest of the nation
the emirates presence though has only
increased divisions on the island
sokotra's governor ramsey marus has
always rejected the presence of the cts
being in his eyes a clear threat to his
figure on the other hand however many
islanders are polarized on the choice to
adapt to support the transnational
council of the south and therefore the
arab emirates or to refuse the
interference of a foreign country in the
island's affairs separated from food and
fuel supplies since the outbreak of the
war the island was left at the mercy of
its own fate the absence of huti on the
island couldn't grant a kazoo's belly to
intervene militarily and so the emirates
with the initial support of the saudis
used the excuse of humanitarian aid to
set foot on the island and secure the
support of part of the population they
found the opportunity in 2015 when in
the space of a few days socotra ended up
being hit by two tropical cyclones that
brought destruction and further misery
to the population that had already been
living on less than one dollar a day for
decades masquerading it as a large-scale
humanitarian intervention by the red
crescent abu dhabi deployed over 5 000
troops to the island without the
coordination or approval of either the
yemeni government or the governor of
socotra in 2018 the united arab emirates
under the guise of training local yemeni
forces in socotra reportedly began to
weave a series of personal interests on
the island first of all they did it to
strengthen military connection with all
their bases along the horn of africa
such as the berbera base and somaliland
the assab noble base in eritrea and
other military barracks in pontland in
somalia from a strategic point of view
socotra provides a vital link between
these regions and would allow the
emirate navi to conduct important
security operations in terms of
contrasting piracy the island has long
been a docking base for many of the
somali pirates who operate far and wide
along the horn of africa as far as the
omani coast a stable presence would also
allow the emirates and implicitly the
saudis to keep out iranian boats that
transport arms and supplies to the
houthi rebels in a proxy war against
iran all of this would strengthen saudi
arabia in this conflict socotra would
serve as an excellent support base from
which to launch rockets against the
houthis in yemen the news that the
emirates used socultura as a military
base is still a matter of debate given
the logistical problems of the island
such as those dictated by the climate
and by monsoons which for six months of
the year make operations in the era very
difficult the interest of the united
arab emirates in socotra has been
interpreted as a challenge by saudi
arabia by occupying the island the
emirates are trying to block the
expansion and the regional domination of
saudi arabia in the entire region
consolidating their presence in the
triangle that at its vertices touches
aidan socotra and the small island of
barim and so the reasons that led abu
dhabi to be guaranteed a 99-year
concession by president hadi would be
mainly economic controlling socra would
mean acquiring a large slice of the
monopoly in the traffic of oil and gas
that passes through babel mandeb a move
made in total autonomy and in contrast
with both iran and saudi arabia with the
occupation of socotra the emirates would
also be able to acquire kilometers and
kilometers of indian ocean through the
strengthening of an exclusive economic
zone in the territorial waters around
the island for the saudis the emirates
are an alliance of convenience it's not
by chance that the emirates are planning
to annex socotra by organizing a
referendum in order to make the
islanders decide whether to become
officially part of the emirates or
remain at the mercy of the uncertainty
of war feeling neglected by hadi's
central government the sokotrians had no
choice but to welcome abu dhabi's
investments the emiratis have not only
built basic infrastructures such as
roads hospitals and schools but also
paid the salaries of doctors policemen
and bureaucrats creating new
opportunities for a total of five
thousand new jobs after two weeks in may
2018 the emirati troops abandoned the
island they got replaced by saudi troops
but they still left behind officials who
are working for the khalifa foundation
of abu dhabi a government-sponsored
charity for governor marusa however such
charitable organizations would conceal a
more devious objective that is to buy
the loyalty of socotra residents and
allow uai traders and investors to
conduct business on the island under
their cover these organizations would
facilitate the purchase of land to
wealthy emiratis despite the presence of
a government decree prohibiting the sale
of any land on the island many of these
lots would belong to protected coastal
areas in which the construction of
buildings and changes to the landscapes
are prohibited yet when buying land with
prices ranging from hundreds of
thousands to tens of millions of dollars
emiratis have never hidden their goals
of building private houses and tourist
resorts emirates and no longer yemen
seem to have become the headquarters of
the island witness to these are the
emirati companies which have weekly
flights between hadibu the capital of
socotra and abu dhabi the united arab
emirates are also aware that socotra may
become a great catalyst for tourism
before the civil war the island operated
a particular kind of ecotourism
respectful of the environment which
granted a small number of visas per year
especially to scientists to facilitate
their study of social ecosystem all of
these may disappear with the emirati
occupation and with their plans to favor
luxury resorts all over the island just
like they already did in dubai with
their artificial archipelagos i dare to
say that the objective is very simple to
transform socotra into a dubai 2.0 to do
so socotra's deputy governor for
environment and development abdul jameel
mohammed as well as emirati companies
have reportedly already begun excavating
several sections of the island's
national park in preparation for a
series of five-star resorts leaving
aside the contradictions of seeing
five-star hotels in villages still
destroyed by monsoons and poverty all of
this has raised a lot of criticism in
the island as reported by local sources
the emirates didn't obtain any
permission from yemen to start their
construction projects in addition to
this some reports highlighted that
several endangered species both plants
and animals have been taken from the
island and resettled into the emirates
many soccotians saw this move as not
only a violation of the island's
identity but also as an offense against
their environment something made
possible by the position of supremacy
enjoyed by emirati officials there the
possibility of the island being used as
a new destination for vacationing has
raised concerns related to pollution of
a fragile ecosystem and maybe this is
the saddest element of the story also
the fact that the emirates several
months later send troops on the island
again
doesn't bode well abu dhabi doesn't seem
willing to leave the bone which is
metaphorically the island in the hands
of the saudis for this is what's all
about a bone an island that's at risk of
being stripped of its beauty for mere
geopolitical and economic plots yemeni
journalist muhammad al-rumeem earlier
this year said the united arab emirates
are not a friend of socotra they're only
interested in colonizing it the emirates
have always denied the accusation of
neo-colonialism but what seems more and
more certain is that the emiratis intend
to keep their presence on the island
with or without yemeni approval on the
one hand this allows the emirates to
avoid open conflicts with the arabs and
other competitors such as israel which
seems to have an intelligent space on
the island on the other hand it
relegates the islanders to
mere pawns in a geopolitical chess game
whose outcome could prove catastrophic
for their traditional lifestyle and also
for the island they call home only time
will tell us which side will prevail
they say however that time is a
gentleman but i have serious doubts that
it will be so in this case i thank all
of you for listening and keeping me
company until the end see you in the
next video bye